I know it's crazy I'm wearing shirts now
hey Marvel fans Ryan Panaji Ock agent M
here with the VFX supervisor of Marvel
Studios Avengers endgame dandle oh how
you doing damn good how are you very
well I would love to talk about the Hulk
one of my favorite reveals in the movie
is when we see the new smart hawk he's
very classy he's got great fashion sense
wonderful glasses where did you and the
team start to look at developing this
this new this new look for Hulk well we
started with a couple different ways we
had you know there's kind of the look
dev they started kind of experimenting
with different ideas how much Ruffalo
how much Hulk and so it was making sure
that we could have just enough a rough
low there that you'd you know you
believe him as a character and help us
to you know bring that character to life
by what we could do with bringing the
animation to an emotion capture into it
mark doing the motion capture and it
seems like he's just having a ball he's
like ad-libbing and even though he's
dabbing yeah what is that like for you
as someone who's creating all this and
being able to express this amazing CGI
character with someone like Mark it's
that partnership I think is key when you
get someone of the caliber of Mark
Ruffalo he can bring so much because he
knows the characters journey through the
film's you know how brilliant of an
actor he is and then suddenly he's
bringing that to you and and then for
the visual effects side of it you want
to be in a place that you have the
artistry and the technology at a place
that can actually incorporate that into
the final visual effect his face is so
elastic in as big cheeks it's like you
need to be able to get all of that and
kind of one to get you out of the
uncanny valley and to just to make you
know realize that it's mark and and kind
of some of the first tests we did and
when we finally got all the software
working it's just it's like magic you
know you've got him in the diner and
there's this one shot that's my favorite
shot in the film where he's like you
know cokes they're eating a giant stack
of pancakes and eggs and you've actually
got the digital character you know
talking with his mouth full of food yeah
it's hard enough to get the lip sync to
work correctly but suddenly he's
actually you know around the food it's
like oh my god it's working
this is amazed
I love that diner scene as I was
rewatching actually where mark is in the
suit in the motion capture suit I just
got fascinated with the fact that there
was an actual crepe and then I you know
you watched the final version and then
there's this digital crepe and and
Hulk's hand and I just find it
fascinating of how you and the team put
hulk in the scene with all these other
characters and how this all comes
together the key to all those making all
this work the biggest thing you can do
is make the after comfortable one set
there in this giant helmet with a camera
on the front of it and this crazy outfit
that we used to be able to track it with
cameras without you know a lot of times
people will try to do that just in like
a motion capture volume that's separate
from set and if you can you want to be
able to put them on set with their other
actors so they can listen to each other
and play off each other and then you
give them things like the crepes and the
sausages so that they can actually feel
like they're that carrot that keraton
seen so you know it's a way to keep the
scene from becoming sterile because a
lot of times with visual effects you
know when you just got a giant blue
screen out there it's kind of will take
the actress out of it I want to talk
about the taco scene one the internet
loves them that Hulk giving tacos to
scott scene i think it is wonderful it's
so sweet and when you talk about you
know Mark taking hulk on this journey
and the character and the way he's
developed I also am just fascinated by
this massive CGI character handing these
tiny little tacos I assume that was all
VFX
yeah it was all the effects we had you
know mark on set and he had real tacos
that he could handle Paul sometimes
he'll get lucky and you can keep the
real tacos sometimes you can't you know
with the case with hope you always had
so much bigger than mark we ended up
replacing them and it was really sweet
love it when we're talking about the way
that the Hulk has evolved now we see our
Paul going back to the Battle of New
York and seeing his more aggressive side
how how do you as the VFX team work with
mark to actually express the the sort of
reluctant Hulk if you look at the
different films you go from the first
Avengers to Ultron to Ragnarok you know
the Hulk model changed throughout the
films and so because we were travelling
back in time
we actually just went back and
resurrected the actual sculpt of Hulk
from the first Avengers and started with
that and then when we started with safar
Hulk we knew he was gonna be because of
the merging a banner and hoped he'd be a
little bit smaller right so the Hulk
himself he's about eight foot eight foot
five
yeah it'll slouch a little bit if you
compare him to Thanos he's actually
taller than Thanos except when he
slashes so we made him about seven foot
five so we used the proportions from the
first Avengers and then kind of started
manipulating from there and kind of
putting some more banners humanity into
the into the Hulk and to into a sculpt
we got the first kind of turntables back
and on his face you captured mark you
captured his face and then when
everybody saw it they all thought well
he's really handsome you know and it was
like and we kept getting it so it's like
you know you know folks got game Amy's
gonna go in on dates over the five years
I imagine that you have a computer that
is just like Hulk and you have sliders
for like you know making smaller making
them larger like more handsome more
handsome more handsome and he's like you
know hearts all around them and
everybody's like I want that computer I
love all those little details and I'm
sure we're gonna see tons more when
Marvel Studios Avengers end game hits
digital and blu-ray thanks so much for
being here down thank you appreciate it
[Music]